they may take our lives but they'll
never take out of twitch 700 years after
the Wars of Independence the fight for a
free Scotland could be won through a
simple vote
basically on September 18 Scottish
people will choose whether or not to
leave the United Kingdom behind in a
referendum polls show it could go either
way and the battleground goes beyond the
ballot box to social media on the one
side you've got the yes Scotland camp
who are angry with the government in
London for using their tax money however
it sees fit tweeting things like
governing classes who consider people's
lives to exist only in balance sheets
deserve to lose the support of those
they govern and the mass movement from
no des is being driven by people
realizing they have been lied to their
whole lives and a lot of people suspect
caton wheels baby announcement was a
well-timed distraction gooner ear said
vote yes Scotland before you have
another royal baby to support hashtag
yes Scotland on the other side the
better together camp is trending with
tweets like everyone in UK understands
the romanticism of having a Braveheart
nation but the reality is stark austere
and irreversible hashtag better together
it all feels a bit like Twilight's team
edward and team jacob except instead of
vampires vs werewolves you've got scotch
vs gin and tonic pets are also being
dragged into the fight and irish artists
in belfast weighed in with some
surprising support the better together
campaign does have the backing of
british celebs like harry potter author
JK Rowling who tweeted people with four
flags answers not slogans reason not
ranting unity not emiti cooter position
have something to do with Hogwarts being
in Scotland because there can be no
borders in the fight against he who must
not be named so what would an
independent Scotland even look like
there's lots of unknowns like whether
the country would stick with the pound
Mike Moffat tweeted the only way and I
mean the only way an independent
Scotland makes sense is if they have
their own currency John rental says
there's nothing wrong with an
independent Scotland using the pound but
then it wouldn't be independent
economist Paul Krugman also warned that
quote everything that has happened in
Europe since 2009 or so has demonstrated
that sharing a currency without sharing
a government it's very dangerous it's a
tough choice ah if only William Wallace
had had Twitter
subscribe on YouTube follow us on
Twitter and like us on Facebook